brett is in columbia south carolina
hi brett welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel hey what's up
uh well first off i just wanted to uh
congratulate kurt
and julieta on getting debt-free that's
awesome i can't wait to be there
very cool i joined in july uh i'm on
baby step two now
uh we've already paid seven uh 7 300 out
of the
53 500 that we owe great job
on our debt yeah and uh we're in the
process of getting our
house refinanced for a 15-year 2.6
interest uh mortgage so we're hoping to
have our house paid off uh by 20 30.
great yeah um but uh anyway
so my question for you today is um
me and my wife we've been working the
baby steps like i said we're on baby
step two
but we've come to a point now where uh
we've got
kind of a fork in the road it's uh uh
basically we're looking at our cell
phone bill and we're wondering
if we should go ahead and pay off our
cell phones
um to lower our bill from about 260 a
month to 195
or if we should take the 680 dollars
that it's going to take to
pay that off to pay off another debt
which is
682 dollars so it's
we're like right there at it and i'm
just like you know i see the financial
advantages of
lowering our monthly bill but at the
same time i'm like we can go ahead and
knock out
that debt and be out of it
well you got to pay it off this time or
next time right
we're not going to keep the cell phone
debt right
right right no no and actually it's both
for cell phones uh the 682 dollars
that is the debt that we owe is uh
is actually where my wife bought a new
cell phone last year
okay and she financed it through an
outside company the uh
the 680 that's that were kind of like
paying credit i'm confused
i'm confused both of them are debts both
of them are cell phones
and both of them are around 680 why
would you just not pay both of them off
well that's what i'm asking is it's uh
the cell phones that we're paying
through a t
it's part of our service contract and
we're paying it through our service
contract
you finance your cell phone with at t
your wife financed her
cell phone with one outside of a t
correct they're both debts okay
so you're saying it doesn't matter which
one you pay off because in the end
you're going to
be paying off one of them anyway at the
rate
you're right you're paying down that
you're probably going to pay them both
off this month aren't you
oh yeah yeah i've been selling anything
that's not nailed down so
you've been doing good all right am i
missing something no so brett is that
does that answer your question is that
what you were wondering
yeah i guess so um i just didn't know i
i figured
i guess we should probably
yeah this is the this is the evil part
of a t and t
and verizon and so forth okay when they
finance your cell phone
into your phone bill you don't think of
it as debt
right yeah and that's that's that's the
great mystery
of how they pulled us pulled that wool
over our eyes
it's still debt you still borrowed money
as opposed to when i get a cell phone
they're either giving me one because of
the contract we're on
um or i'm paying for it right then when
i pick it up
one of the two it's going on you know
we're paying for it immediately so we
don't finance cell phones over
on payments whether it is with the cell
phone company
or with an outside party and since you
have then we're just going to get rid of
that yeah but they did they've changed
that over the past couple of years where
it's like kind of this like finagled
thing within your bill
it is and it can be very very confusing
and so intentionally
confusing 100 because they totally want
you to finance it yep
and they totally don't want you looking
at the interest rate they totally don't
want
they just want to make it easy for you
easy for you that's what they want yeah
beware of these people man i'm telling
you it's just like
anybody's going to make it easy yeah
that that's a problem